[Musique]
la guerre russo ukrainiennes se joue sur
le champ de bataille mais une guerre de
l'information est également en cours
avec ces médias d'état c'est armée de
trolls et ses capacités informatiques
la russie est connue depuis des années
comme une puissance propagandistes de
redoutables et avec cette guerre sa
machine de propagande et de
désinformation est pleinement enclenché
la russie tente de convaincre ses
citoyens que cette invasion n'en est pas
une étant aussi d'influencer les
opinions et semé la confusion en
occident mais son plan se déroule-t-il
comme prévu
avec 6 rapin vous êtes chercheur
résidence à l'observatoire des confits
multidimensionnelle à la chaire raoul
dandurand bonjour bonjour
vous intéressez à la cyber stratégie la
désinformation
en ce moment a réussi on sait qu'elle
tente de convaincre sa population tels
et en ukraine papou envahir le pays mais
pour des nazifié le pays paul
démilitarisé est-ce que ce message là il
passe au sein des populations aux russes
de l'extérieur l'impression qui se
dégage c'est à tout le moins qu'une
large part de la population russe ne
crois pas vraiment qui est bel et bien
un conflit de haute intensité qui se
déroule en ce moment en ukraine et ce
qui peut être y croit en tout cas ne ne
pense pas du tout que les troupes russes
connaissent des difficultés sur le
terrain les médias russes en fait thèse
complètement le récit des affrontements
ils mettent beaucoup plus l'emphase par
exemple sur
les habitants du thon base qui sont
venus se réfugier entre guillemets en
russie sur comment les sanctions
économiques occidentales vont en fait se
retourner contre les occidentaux
réception de choses
ont même vu d'ici c'est sûr que ça nous
paraît un peu enormissime que la caisse
et éléphant dans la pièce qui restent
cachés mais je pense qu'il faut bien
voir que
finalement c'est un narratif ou une
absence de narratif que l'opinion
publique russe est majoritairement bien
disposés à croire donc par une
population qui a une vision du monde
très différente de la nôtre quelle
mémoire historique très différente de la
nôtre et qui qui a aussi des habitudes
de consommation médiatique en fait bien
différentes des nôtres a commencé leurs
convictions sont encensés reims est ce
que vous pouvez d'abord et là dessus
mais sur la question par exemple du
narratif de la dénazification
c'est un discours qui vient jouer en
fait sur une sur une mémoire nationale
russe qui s'ancre en fait d'un d'une
guerre mondiale et puis c'est parce que
les russes en fait appel la grande
guerre patriotique la lutte qu'ils ont
menée contre l'allemagne nazie
pendant la guerre et qui
restent dans les mémoires à certains
égards comme un traumatisme parce que
c'était vraiment une hécatombe
générations entières de russes qui
étaient décimées par ce conflit d'un
mais ça reste aussi comme une très
grande fierté en fait où
la russie conserve cette image d'un pays
qui a tenu contre vents et marées façon
envahisseurs qui a sacrifié énormément
pour obtenir cette victoire est donc
quand on quand le kremlin parle de
dénazification c'est pas un hasard c'est
combien activer ses ressorts mémorielle
pour justement
mettre à profit ce 7e mois patriotisme
qui qui persistent à bien des égards j
et quelle sorte de propagande russe vise
la population à l'extérieur de la russie
c'est quoi le genre de désinformation de
propagande qu'on voit
mais pour tout dire on n'en voit pas
beaucoup en fait et pour quelqu'un comme
moi qui s'intéressent à ces questions
depuis quelques temps ça laisse un petit
peu perplexe je pense qu'une explication
possible c'est que il ya bel et bien des
efforts russe pour orienter le narratif
mais qui grosso modo en ce moment sont
sont complètement éclipsé eux noyés en
fait par le torrent de contenus
favorable à l'ukraine une autre
explication que qu'avant certains
spécialistes c'est que
quelque part la nature des événements
actuellement est défavorable aux
techniques de désinformation rue ce
qu'on avait l'habitude de voir jusqu'ici
l'argument en somme c'est que le la
russie dans les dernières années s'est
montré très bonne pour la jouer sur les
clivages socio politique qui fracturent
les opinions publiques dans les pays
occidentaux instrumentaliser des
mécontentements populaires et quelque
part en fait semer la discorde en fait
alimenté le cynisme et ses terrains et
bella en fait on est face à une
situation où quelqu'un complètement
différente où il ya un narratif en fait
qui est plutôt positif un espèce
d'enthousiasmé vis-à-vis de la ténacité
des ukrainiens par exemple et surtout
une situation dans laquelle c'est la
russie elle même qui doit empêcher des
fractures que que des fractures secret
au sein de l'opinion publique et
peut-être que on est en train de
découvrir que là la machine
informationnel russian de l'appeler
comme ça peut-être pas aussi bonne à ce
jeu là est ce que certains groupes de
personnes certains groupes de citoyens
un accident qui adhèrent aux messages
russe
en occident je pense que oui je pense
que oui il y avait déjà de départ de
l'opinion publique était plutôt
favorable à la russie qui sur des
événements comme le la guerre en syrie
où est le même le confident dont bas
c'était déjà quand même voilà c'est
assez prompte adopté la vision
rue des événements et je pense que c'est
vrai aussi de pas mal de régions en fait
en dehors de l'occident on peut penser à
l'afrique par exemple ou voilà il ya une
méfiance de longue date vis-à-vis de
l'occident qu'on peut d'ailleurs très
bien comprendre
et où on est donc beaucoup plus prompt
en fait avoir la russie comme communiste
de force du bien sur la scène
internationale comme un pays sur lequel
on peut compter pour réparer les torts
causés dans l'occident sur la scène
internationale ces alliances et
évidemment en afrique comme un seul bloc
on a vu par exemple que le kenya par
exemple condamné c'est vraiment la
russie en disant voilà nous on doit
vivre avec les frontières issues de la
colonisation
pourquoi la russie aurait le droit de
décider unilatéralement les frontières
ses frontières à l et un autre une autre
région importantes à considérer notre
pays importants à considérer je pensais
la chine où on voit qu'il ya quand même
un certain attrait pour le narratif
russe des événements d'une part parce
que la chine voit de plus en plus la
russie comme un allié en fait comme son
principal partenaire pour faire bloc
contre les occidentaux sur les questions
internationales et d'autre part en chine
aussi il ya beaucoup de gens qui
considère taïwan comme une partie
intégrante du territoire chinois et qui
envisagent de la reconquête de la
reconquérir un jour par les armes s'il
le faut donc je pense qu'il ya une envie
inavoués peut-être en tout cas pas
présentes explicitement mais il ya une
envie
chez beaucoup de chinois de voir la
chute de la russie réussir son coup pour
un peu crée un précédent qui pourrait
servir la chine dans un avenir plus ou
moins selon vous c'est qui qui gagne
cette guerre de l'information à sa main
il ya différents éléments qui laissent
penser que la stratégie de communication
du kremlin pour le moment elle n'est pas
très très n'est pas très séduisante elle
manque un peu de charme on voit les
images qu'on voit enrichie basse et ses
ombres on voit voilà l'admirent poutine
et ses généraux qui sont seuls autour de
grandes tables dans d immenses pièces un
peu austère du kremlin ils se parlent
entre eux de la situation mais il
s'adresse pas les yeux dans les yeux à
la population par exemple alors que côté
ukrainien on voit émerger et se propager
en fait des histoires de vie des récits
très personnelles auxquelles les gens
ordinaires peuvent pour la plus
facilement s'identifier et pour
lesquelles on peut plus facilement
développée de l'empathie voire de la
sympathique donc je pense qu'il ya une
espèce de force narrative un pouvoir de
séduction entre guillemets dont le cren
jouer en ce moment et dans la rue si je
jouais beaucoup moins